it can actually be pretty tough to get
actors to share their true feelings of
other films especially if they're the
films they'd rather not talk about
fortunately a handful of stars have
opened up over the years and taken aim
at the worst movies of their career in
2002 Halle Berry delivered a tearful
impassioned speech on the Oscar stage
clutching the Best Actress statuettes
she just earned for a performance and
monsters ball three years later she
brought that same statuette with her to
accept her Razzie award for worst
actress in the super zero flop Catwoman
berry delight to the audience with her
snide speech in which she thanked studio
Warner Brothers proposing her in what
she called a god-awful movie Barry went
on to say it was just what my career
needed you know I was at the top and
then Catwoman has plummeted me to the
bottom although her Catwoman speech has
since gone down in Hollywood legend
Barry's attitude towards the movie has
mellowed in recent years in a 2018
acceptance speech this time for The
Matrix Award for New York women in
communication Barry said of her ratty
winning role what have failed to most
people it wasn't a failure for me
because I met so many interesting people
that I wouldn't have met otherwise and
learned two forms of martial arts and I
learned not what to do it also helps she
added that the film made her a
life-changing amounts of money
Dev Patel found stardom early in his
career with the oscar-winning Slumdog
Millionaire
so naturally everyone was pretty curious
about his next film 2010's Avatar The
Last Airbender it was a huge studio
movie with huge expectations and an even
bigger budget of course once it theaters
the movie became hated by pretty much
everyone on earth and for a while Patel
didn't really want to talk about it back
in 2014 the most he said on the matter
was yeah that wasn't the best move was
it Patel opened up a little further in a
2016 roundtable interview with The
Hollywood Reporter I completely felt
overwhelmed by the experience I felt
like I wasn't being heard
still Patel pointed out that making the
movie had been a learning experience for
him that's really when I learned the
power of no the idea of saying no
because I was 18 or something and I was
just like okay how he but that may have
made Daniel Radcliffe a household name
but that still doesn't mean he's fond of
every film in the series in 2014
Radcliffe told The Daily Mail that his
favor of the
choices order of the Phoenix and that
the sixth movie the half-blood Prince
was Astley's favor of the bunch in 2015
playboy ass Radcliffe to expand on this
and he explained in every movie up to
the sixth one you can see a big step
forward in my acting and then it stops
or went backward maybe in the sixth film
on the sixth I remember watching it and
thinking wow there's been no growth
you're watching a mistake you made every
day for 11 months that's the way I saw
it it probably didn't help that
Radcliffe had started drinking heavily
when he turned 18 the age of which he
filmed the half-blood Prince Radcliffe
didn't explicitly mention this when
discussing his Leigh's favor of the
films but the actor had previously
spoken about his alcohol abuse in 2012
he said that while he never drank on set
he would still be drunk from the night
before and that watching the movies now
I can point to many scenes or I'm just
gone dead behind the eyes
luckily Radcliffe became a teetotaler in
2010 in 2012 when a 3d version of
Titanic docked in theaters for the
film's 15th anniversary Kate Winslet
told CNN every single scene I'm like
really really you did it like this oh my
god I have a hard time watching any of
my performances but watching Titanic I
was just like oh god I want to do that
again it might be surprising to hear
that Winslet wants to keep up
performance as Rosa second go given what
she went through the first time around
director James Cameron was notoriously
aggressive on set Winslet told the LA
Times
there were times where I was genuinely
frightened of him on top of that winds
that nearly drowned while shooting one
scene and Cameron made her do it right
after again and the since dismiss her
claim that she was in real danger
she also chipped a bone came out with
various bruises and scrapes and was
regularly paid to perform in cold water
for close-ups she was even submerged 12
feet underwater and weighted down so she
wouldn't move no wonder she doesn't like
watching her in recent years actors as
prestigious as Robert Redford and
Anthony Hopkins have taken major roles
in superhero films but there's one
two-time Oscar winner who seriously
regrets joining the world of comic book
movies as it turns out Sully field
thoughts of artists aren't me and the
amazing spider-man movies was an
absolute bore in an appearance on the
Howard Stern Show
field talked in depth about Sony's
failed attempt at a trilogy
spider-man you didn't like that movie
I'm not especially it's not my kind of
movie
also added that she did it for a friend
amazing spider-man producer Laura Ziskin
who died a year before the film was
released but field also admitted that
she didn't put a great deal of thought
into the character you you work it as
much as you can but you you know you
can't put you know 10 pounds of 5 pound
bag still filled manage to find the
bright side in all the mess according to
the actress working with Andrew Garfield
was at least a lot of fun
in 2010 Jessica Alba told L magazine
that shooting Fantastic Four rise of the
Silver Surfer nearly made her quit
acting as director Tim story apparently
made Albert alter abilities and her
career choice evidently story didn't
like the way she was crying in a scene
because it looked too real according to
Albert the director then asked her to
cry pretty as Alba puts it and then it's
all got me thinking am I not good enough
and my instincts and my emotions not
good enough do people hate them so much
so they don't want me to be a person and
so I just said yeah I don't care about
this business anymore Alba was as good
as her word in 2012 she traded Hollywood
for business setting up the honest
company which focuses on selling natural
baby products according to Forbes stuff
first year her company made 10 million
dollars in revenue Alba that expanded to
beauty products in 2015 and she raised
200 million dollars in funding in 2018
and although Alba is selecting today the
fact that Forbes estimates her company
to be worth 200 million dollars yes sir
now if she ever changes her mind
since the rise and demise of his
relationship with Angelina Jolie you kid
made the case of Brad Pitt has become
more famous for his personal life than
face movie career but back in the 90s
Brad Pitt was a bona fide movie star
although he still occasionally had some
pretty blunt comments to make about the
movies have made him a household name
for example in 1997 pick called out the
devil's own in which he starred as an
undercover IRA terrorists opposite
Harrison Ford Pitt told Newsweek we had
no script well we had a great script but
it got tossed for various reasons
according to Pitts the casting crew were
forced to make something up as they went
along and move that pic called the most
irresponsible bits of filmmaking as he
had ever seen he also called outs then
head of Columbia studios Marc can turn
forcing production to continue Pitts
apparently regretted his comment shortly
afterwards however adding in a follow-up
interview everyone was
working hard we weren't trying to just
throw out a Krupp film you know we were
doing our best the Indiana Jones series
is nearly a perfect franchise with the
exception of Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull that is although to be fair
crystal skull actually did pretty well
when it came out in 2008 at least
box-office wise but in the year since
it's come under severe scrutiny for its
supposed betrayal of the classic Indiana
Jones spirit in fact a Shia LaBeouf who
played a motorcycle punk named nuts said
that both he and director Steven
Spielberg had dropped the ball on the
movie in 2018 he went back on the attack
again this time taking aim at the after
mark to Michael Bay directed
Transformers franchise that made him a
star LaBeouf told Esquire might hang up
with those films was that they felt
irrelevant you'd come up on these
stories about Easy Rider and Raging Bull
and De Niro and Scorsese and hopper and
you find value in what they do
meanwhile you're chasing Energon
crystals after getting his fill of
blockbusters LaBeouf moved toward
performance art but many still remember
him as a guy who bit the hand that fed
him long before he took the role of the
Caped Crusader Robert Pattinson launched
his career with the Battie role of
another kind quite a tourist Lee
Pattinson got his big break playing a
vampire in the Twilight series although
Edward Cullen was more sparkly than
sinister based on a series of y-a novels
the Twilight franchise was loved and
loathed with almost equal passion and
Pattinson found himself firmly on the
latter side of the equation in
interviews during the sagas many press
toss his comments tended to range from
anywhere between bewildered it's a lot
of stuff in the toilet world that
doesn't make any sense to frustrated
Harvey gets do any vampires
I mean can I get to kill anyone I really
want to kill some people so I'll try to
belligerence the stories are so serious
and instead of and so kind of
melodramatic in a way and it is
literally life or death all the time
since the final installment came out in
2012 but incentives mostly stuck to more
artistic movies however he's managed to
find a few positive things about
Twilight since then admitting that since
the intensity around the films has died
down he has learned to appreciate fans
enjoyment of it far more he even found
one part of the film that he enjoyed
telling USA Today New Moon genuinely
does have an incredible soundtrack I
completely forgot but the soundtracks
were quite ahead of their time Jamie Lee
Curtis impressed fans and critics alike
when she returns a hadn't failed in 2018
s Halloween but it's even though Curtis
has also starred in classics like a Fish
Called Wanda and True Lies her Hollywood
record isn't exactly spotless according
to Curtis the worst movie she ever made
was virus a movie about a tugboat crew
that stumbles upon an almost abandoned
ship before things get all kinds of
crazy well the premise might sound
awesome critics hated the film and
Curtis clearly wasn't happy with it
either in 2012 she told IGN that's when
she and her movie star friends compared
bad movies viruses her trump card she
explained that's the only good reason to
be in bad movies then when your friends
have bad movies you can say ah I've got
the best one I'm bringing virus when
you've got a career as long and varied
as Michelle Pfeiffer's you're bound to
have starred in a dirt every now and
again
luckily Pfeiffer's low points came with
the very start of her career and it
probably would have been for Gutzon if
it hadn't also happened to be a sequel
to one of the most beloved movies of all
time Pfeiffer starred as pink lady
Stephanie in Greece - four years after
the original movie musical came out
after many misfires during production
the movie barely made back its budget in
2007 she told movie web I hated that
film with a vengeance and could not
believe how bad it was at the time I was
young and didn't know any better I hear
it's a cult movie now thankfully her
next film was Scarface wasted a little
better but fight for a [ __ ] she
wouldn't mind going back to Rydell High
discussing the prospect of another
Greece movie she explained to movie web
I would love to play the school
principal she is fun and has some great
put down lines
bela Fleck already had a long list of
dubious movies under his belt before he
strapped on the utility belt to play
Batman in Zack Snyder's much maligned
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice birth
of all of his awful films Affleck hates
daredevil the most this 2003 adaptation
of the Marvel comic is despised by every
human who's ever stepped inside a movie
theater but the man who loathes that the
most is definitely as leading man before
the release of Batman V Superman Affleck
explained that part of the reason he
wanted to play a superhero again was
because he wanted a second chance at the
genre during his appearance at time
talks he explained part of it was I
wanted for once to get one of these
movies and do it rights to do a good
version I hate daredevil so much
unfortunately his shot at the Batman
franchise didn't quite deliver the
redemption he'd wish for as the movie
was widely panned by critics but hey it
could have been worse in 2018 when the
New York Times asked Davis if there was
a job she wished she had taken by
earlier Davis provoked the question the
dish and a job she wished she'd turned
down and that was the role of a baleen a
black maid working in 1960s Mississippi
who joins a civil rights movement in
2011's the help
Davis was quick to praise her co-stars
and director Tate Taylor before getting
to the reason behind her regret as she
puts it I just felt that at the end of
the day that it wasn't the voices of the
maids that were heard according to Davis
the film which was supposed to be about
black women working and raising children
in 1963 didn't really put their stories
front and center davis was actually
nominated for an Oscar for the role but
there's a good chance he'd rather just
forget it ever happened
Alec Baldwin isn't exactly known for
holding back his opinions and that goes
just the same when it comes to his own
work one of the films is taken aim at
his 2012 rock of ages' a movie based on
a stage musical that features a loose
plot constructed around covers of
classic rock songs the movie failed to
rock critics worlds and no one was less
surprised than Baldwin who admitted that
those coast styles were wide signed up
in the first place in 2013 Baldwin told
New York editor David Remnick it was a
complete disaster a week in you go oh
god what have I done indeed in 2011
before filming and even begun
Baldwin asked new lines to replace them
supposedly this was due to an
unspecified medical condition but give
Baldwin thinks he made what he called a
horrible movie it could well have been a
premonition of the flop to come this
theory seems especially valid given that
Baldwin also claimed actors know full
well when they have a dud on their hands
he explained the plane is buffeting the
engine is on fire millions of kids have
grown up wanting to be GI Joe but when
Channing Tatum got the chance he was
actually less than thrilled in 2015 a
six years after GI Joe the Rise of Cobra
came out Tatum told Howard Stern that's
after receiving the script he found
himself a little less than thrilled at
the idea of taking the role but do you
have no option to say no option you know
but hey there you do it you're doing it
we're gonna sue you he also admits it to
being wary of the role in the first
place because it been such a fan of the
show during his youth I don't want to do
something that like I won rim of
fairness since I was a kid I watch it
every morning like growing up he
explained to stern that's after his
first movie role on 2005 s coach Carter
he signed a three-picture deal with
Paramount they cashed in part of that
deal with GI Joe and informs Tatum that
they would sue him if he refused to make
the film luckily Tatum's career
recovered and in 2015 he was a 13th
highest-paid actor in the world but GI
Joe wasn't done with him after Cobra
perhaps unfortunately for Tatum he also
went on to appear in the 2013 sequel GI
Joe retaliation while he may have found
superstardom with roles in classic
movies like The Terminator predator
Arnold Schwarzenegger still starred in a
few duds in his time in 1985 he appeared
in red Sonia which was supposed to be
the story of a vengeful female warrior
even though Arnie got Top Billing
confusingly although the character of
Red Sonja originally appeared as a
sidekick for Conan the Barbarian in
Marvel Comics and swash onager had
already played Conan twice by this point
Red Sonja finds actors playing a totally
different sword wielding muscle-bound
warrior named Khalid or unfortunately
swastikas performance was less than
charming the New York Times pointed out
that his character quote might as well
have been played by a maple tree and
Schwarzenegger seems to agree
he once said of the flick it's the worst
film I have ever made now when my kids
get out of line they're sent to their
room and forced to watch Red Sonja ten
times I never have too much trouble with
them check out one of our newest videos
right here Plus even more looper videos
about
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one